Don the family needs you  Valentino what are you doing it you  don't leave the family Don blood in  blood out si I left that life behind me  plus the boss insists you come you don't  say no to the boss Don goddamnit  Valentino right when I thought I was out  they pull me back in Humphrey ciabatta  aka the camel if we need somebody  clipped we Sano free every heist needs  firepower and the camels top notch  Valentino salami  aka the Flamingo Valentino's an actor  pickup artist big honour and God knows  what else he distracts me  we carry off the dull dull spaghetti aka  the dolphin don'ts lives his life  outside the water now but that doesn't  bother him guy gets a standing out of  trouble fast and they ain't even caught  him once  they call me Don the enforcer was strong  and you know what I don't explain myself  to you jump